ein härteres Durchgreifen verlange ich
erst mal persönlich wenn es notwendig
wird dann ja was ich zwar verlange ist
das was ich eigentlich schon seit 20
Jahren verlange ein schnelles Agieren
der
Strafverfolgungsbehörden weil das ist
zunächst einmal die beste Prävention und
darüber hinaus auch für die Täter
wichtig damit sie nicht wieder in
Erscheinung treten
und ist das derzeit so dass eben nicht
schnell nicht konsequent genug
durchgegriffen wird bei jugendlichen
Straftätern
das kann man so auch nicht sagen wir
haben solche Exzesse hier in den
vergangenen Jahren immer wieder gehabt
ich erinnere an die Silvesternacht von
Köln ich erinnere an die Problematik in
Stuttgart auch da sind junge Leute auf
die Straße gegangen haben dann sich mit
der Polizei
herumgeschlagen haben Straftaten
begangen haben Verstöße hier und da
gegen der Strafgesetzbuch begangen wir
haben wir haben also kein absolut neues
Phänomen also ein besonders seltenes
Ereignis wir haben was was wir immer
wieder haben und wir haben immer wieder
die gleiche Diskussion es geht mir auch
nicht darum ob die Täter jetzt Deutsch
sind ob Sie aus irgendwelchen Ländern
dieser Welt kommen sondern es geht mir
darum dass in Zukunft mal hingeschaut
wird dass man diese Leute
möglichst schnell vor die Richter
bekommt den kann man auch analysieren
welche Wut dazu gebracht hat so zur
agieren man muss gegebenenfalls auch mal
harter Hand rangehen damit es eine
Abschreckung für die Leute ist ist die
bisher noch nicht in Erscheinung
getreten sind und das geht nur durch
schnelles und effektives Arbeiten der
Justiz insbesondere der
Staatsanwaltschaft und dann gehören die
Sachen ganz schnell auf die
richtertische wir haben eben gerade
gesehen als sie geantwortet haben es gab
eben auch 2020 Vorfälle die uns in
Erinnerung geblieben sind aus Stuttgart
also absolut richtig kein Berliner
sondern ein deutschlandweites Problem
aber gehen wir jetzt noch mal auf die
Silvesternacht auf Berlin ein denn das
ist ja auch jetzt sehr in der der
öffentlichen Debatte wie sehen sie also
wie sehr sehen sie deine Chancen dass
jetzt die 145 Verdächtigen dass es da
dann aber auch zu konsequenten schnellen
vielleicht urteilen wenn nötig kommt
die sehe ich sehr wohl man hat ja die
Personalien dieser Person da sie in
Gewahrsam genommen wurde nach meiner
Kenntnis gibt es noch viel viel mehr
Ermittlungsverfahren ja dann muss man
schauen wie es die Beweislage und die
Beweislage würde in Einzelfällen relativ
gut sein weil man hör Video Aufzeichnung
hat weil man
Aufzeichnungen der Polizeibeamter hat
weil man auch zeugen von der Polizei
benutzen kann oder sonstige ja und dann
gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten
schnell zu agieren unser Gesetz hat
alles einmal im Jugendstrafrecht der
sogenannte Antragsverfahren da kann man
relativ schnell agieren es ist ehemalige
Neuköllner Modell was leider Gottes
verloren gegangen ist Ermittlung der
Polizei
abzustaatsanwaltschaft von der
Staatsanwaltschaft zum Gericht man
kümmert sich um solche Sachen immer nur
wenn es Exzesse gibt die Politiker die
heute einmal gehen sind und wiederum
nach nach schärferen Gesetzen rufen
waren jahrelang schon in der Lage solche
Strukturen aufzubauen aber wir nehmen an
es sind nicht alle jugendlich sondern
darüber hinaus gibt es auch
heranwachsene also Leute ab 18 da können
Sie das beschleunigte Verfahren wählen
Sie können Anwälte bestellen und können
bis zu einem Jahr verhängen und wenn es
ganz schlimme Straftaten sind dann kann
wenn die Staatsgewalt nämlich die
Staatsanwaltschaft vernünftig schnell
und gut ausgestattet agiert auch hier
ein schnelles Verfahren herbeigeführt
werden und das ist die beste Prävention
für die Zukunft wir haben einen User er
nennt sich myself der fragt bei Youtube
warum werden alle Jugendlichen
eigentlich immer wieder auf freien Fuß
gesetzt genau das löst diese grenzenlose
Respektlosigkeit aus meinte User
das kann ich ihnen einfach sagen
zunächst wird in allen Fällen die
Staatsanwaltschaft gar keinen Antrag bei
den Richtern gestellt haben weil
möglicherweise die Straftat zu gering
ist die Beweise nicht ausreichend oder
aber das dürfte mit entscheidend sein
weil keine Haftgründe vorliegen
Haftgründe sind Fluchtgefahr
Wiederholungsgefahr oder
Verdunklungsgefahr Fluchtgefahr in aller
Regel sowieso nicht und das ist
natürlich auch abhängig davon was den
Täter zu erwarten was der Täter zu
erwarten hat das ist ist sind normale
Regeln der Strafprozessordnung die
gelten für alle die haben immer gleich
golden und die sind auch vernünftig man
sollte jetzt nicht alle sofort in den
Knast packen nur weil sie vor Ort
gewesen sind sondern nur die die es
tatsächlich verdient haben und wo dieser
Haftgründe vorliegen